[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hey guys it's me marina Joyce no but
welcome to the end of another year here
on YouTube here on Susie's world and
what a year it was last year that I can
remember we had this happen and then
this happened and don't forget that this
happened and then this happened which
was pretty much the highlight of my life
and despite YouTube being broken for the
last two months this was still the
biggest year that we had for a
subscriber growth here on Suzy's world
so you may have heard that YouTube is
broken now what does that mean so
basically YouTube is unsubscribing
people from accounts that they're
subscribe to and failing to deliver you
the videos from the channels that you
are subscribed to so what can you do to
make sure that you don't miss my videos
in 2017 well a couple things first make
sure you're subscribed second hit that
Bell button next to the subscribe button
and make sure you turn on notifications
and the third thing you can do is leave
on every video like 50 comments and 20
likes well you can only have one like
per video but the thing is I guess
engagement is now going to be really
important on YouTube so liking and
leaving a comment is gonna be more
important than ever I wouldn't want you
to miss any of the videos in 2017
because there's a lot of great stuff
planned for next year I'm going to be
working with a couple of new
collaborators who you'll meet here in
the coming month actually this is one of
them but you'll get to meet both of them
formally in a short period of time so
with that being said I'll take you out
one last time here in 2016
subscribe to see ZZZ world for new
Horrors every other week and I'll see
you next year assuming be obvious
[Music]
you